>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Good morning, lucky
elementary school.
>> Good morning.
>> Welcome to the Library
of Congress,
and to the Young Readers Center.
Have any of you have been to
the Library of Congress before?
>> No.
>> Yes.
>> I see a few hands.
I see one, two three, four, okay.
Thanks for coming back, and I hope
to see the rest of you again soon.
You're in the biggest library in the
world, but you wouldn't recognize it
in this room, because we,
the Young Readers Center,
it's a newer library, a big
library; the biggest one
in the world, and it's
215 years old.
>> Whoa.
>> But we, the Young Readers
Center, we're only seven years old.
And I'm Karen Jaffe, I'm head
of the Young Readers Center.
And I'm here to invite
you to participate
in a very special program.
And first I'm going
to ask you a question.
When you think of a library,
what do you think of; what?
What's the one thing you
think of in a library?
You can just shout it out.
What is it?
>> Books.
>> Right; and what is it
that we find inside books?
What is it?
What?
>> Pictures?
>> Okay; what else, what?
>> Words.
>> Words. Okay; so we think of
books, and we think of words.
But there are other
things that have words.
And they have things that
go along with the words,
and that's called "music."
And in order to get a song,
you have music, and you have --
>> The words.
>> Words. So today we have two very
special musicians and songwriters,
Cathy Fink, and Marcy Marxer.
And they write their own
songs, they sing them,
and they play instruments.
They do everything.
So now we're looking at a different
way of learning about words,
and what they mean, and
having fun at the same time.
So here you go.
>> Cathy Fink: Hi, everybody.
Well, we are really
excited to be here,
partly because we love
the Library of Congress.
And we do make up or write a lot of
our own songs, but sometimes we go
to libraries, places like
the Library of Congress,
and in fact we've been right
here, and we do research.
We look up old songs.
And we try and find old songs
that maybe people haven't heard
in 200 years, and see if we
can make them come alive.
Now, there's a not so old
song that you already know.
We're not going to sing it
yet; we might sing it later.
But you probably already
know the song called,
"This Land is Your Land."
Do you guys know that?
>> No.
>> Cathy Fink: Not yet, all right?
Well, the man who wrote
that song is very famous.
And the Library of Congress
has a lot of his songs,
maybe a hundred of them, maybe more.
And it is a song that gives us a
chance to say hello to each other.
Now, before we get started,
everybody say hello
with just your hands.
Excellent.
Okay; let's say hello
with just your elbows.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Can you say hello with your ears?
Excellent; you guys are good.
Okay; now we're going to say
hello in a very special way
that Woody Guthrie taught
us how to say hello.
Because there are lots of ways to
say hello, different languages,
just different words in
our English language.
And we're going to
say, "How do you do?"
Everybody say, "How do you do?"
>> How do you do?
>> Cathy Fink: Now, when
we say, "How do you do,"
we're going break a big wave and
smile like this, "How do you do?"
Everybody.
>> How do you do?
>> Cathy Fink: Now, one fun
thing about having music
at the library is we are
allowed to make noise.
A lot of times, the libraries,
they don't want you to make noise
because people are reading, and
studying, and concentrating.
But in this room this morning,
all of our noises are
going to work together.
So whenever Marcy or I say, "How do
you do," you're going to answer us
like this, "How do you do?"
Now, even your teachers
are going to answer us,
because we don't want them to think
that they're not a part of this.
And furthermore, kids, when
you go back to your classroom
and test your teachers if
they haven't practiced,
who knows what they're not
going to be able to [inaudible].
[ Music and Singing ]
>> How'd you do?
You've already met my friend, Marcy,
but right now we're [inaudible] once
upon a time was a homemade washing
machine, [overlapping]--
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Marcy Marxer: And
if we want to --
our original washing machine
didn't have a lot of stuff on it,
it's just this part, the
wooden part, you put the bottom
down into a bucket, and
the water [inaudible] soap
on your dirty clothes
and scrub up and down.
And some people still do
laundry like that today.
But I have a washing machine,
and I'm thankful for that.
So I can play music with
my [inaudible]; like this.
[Sound] It's a woodblock,
[sound] spoon.
[Sound] And this is a lid
of a little old soup pot.
[Sound] I'm going to keep
that over the microphone.
[Sound] Okay, [overlapping].
>> Cathy Fink: Are we ready
to show something out there?
>> Marcy Marxer: One,
two, three, four.
[ Music and Sounds ]
That's not good enough for you.
I'll go faster then.
[ Music and Sounds ]
>> That is called the washboard.
[ Applause and Music ]
All right; this show is
full of trick me questions.
The word "washboard," what
letter does that start with?
>> W.
>> Cathy Fink: W; you
guys are awesome.
All right.
Now, I am playing to a
different instrument,
and it's not a washboard.
What is it?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
It's a banjo; awesome.
And so here's what the banjo
sounds like all by itself.
Sometimes it's loud and fast.
[ Banjo Plays ]
And sometimes it's
very quiet and pretty.
Listen to this.
[ Banjo Plays ]
And what letter does
"banjo" start with?
>> B.
>> Cathy Fink: B; you
guys are awesome.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> How'd you do?
All right; you guys are so awesome.
>> Marcy Marxer: You are.
>> Cathy Fink: I think we're
going to play the banjo together.
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh,
that's a good idea.
>> Cathy Fink: Okay?
>> Marcy Marxer: That's a good idea.
>> Cathy Fink: And so the
first thing we need to do
to play the banjo together
is we all need banjos.
What is this shape?
>> A circle.
>> Cathy Fink: It's a circle.
So everybody take one
hand and draw a circle.
Perfect. All right; now we're
going to draw the neck of the banjo
up one side and down the other.
And we are going to
draw five strings.
So let's count while we draw,
one, two, three, four, five.
>> One, two, three, four, five.
>> Cathy Fink: Perfect.
Now, how many hands does
it take to play the banjo?
>> Two.
>> Cathy Fink: Two hands.
Watch what happens.
And right in front of the circle,
one hand strums on
the strings, right?
Try that, strumming the strings.
[ Banjo Plays ]
Excellent.
Now, if I never do
anything with my left hand,
that's the only sound you're
ever going to hear [banjo plays],
which is really a nice sound, but
it could get boring after a while.
And so I use the fingers
on this hand
to play all the different notes.
[ Banjo Plays ]
So we've got to use first one
hand, and add the other hand.
[ Banjo Plays ]
You can play both hands at once.
Excellent.
Now, when I sing a song with you,
I have to make my right hand go,
my left hand go, and
sing at the same time.
Three things; isn't that crazy?
I must be incredible.
Oh, but you're incredible,
all right?
So here's how the song goes.
[ Music and Singing ]
Let's try that together.
And now get your right hand
going, and your left hand.
Here we go.
[ Music and Singing ]
Everybody sing.
Everybody.
[ Music and Singing ]
All right; now sometimes
I can play my banjo fast.
If I play my banjo
fast, what are you going
to do; play your banjos fast.
If I play my banjo slow,
what are you doing to do?
>> Play slow.
>> Cathy Fink: Now, I know
all the kids can get it,
but I'm going to see if I
can trick some teachers here.
Even Miss Jaffe from
the Library of Congress,
let's see if she could
do any of this.
Are you ready?
Pay attention.
[ Music ]
Everybody.
[ Music and Singing ]
Now, that is an example
of a song that I made up.
And some people say when you make
up a song, you've written a song.
And you might wonder, "Well,
how does that happen?"
It happens in so many
different ways.
But first with me,
I was just sitting
around one day playing my
banjo, just doing this.
[ Banjo Plays ]
And I was looking out my back
window and along came a bird,
and I thought, "Well, I'll
sing to that bird; why not?"
And then I started, "If I had
a banjo, I'm going to sing,
sing to the birds and break of --
" and then I got to the last word
and it had to rhyme with "sing."
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Spring, that's what I went for.
But there's lots of other
rhyming words with "sing."
What's another word?
[ Overlapping Comments ]
"Thing," yes.
>> "Sing."
>> Cathy Fink: "Ring," yes.
[ Overlapping Comments ]
I had so many choices.
And you know what happens when you
write songs, when you make up songs,
you have to make those choices,
"Which one of these words
is going to sound best?"
Well, we're going to make some
choices right now when we make
up a song altogether,
completely make up -- watch this.
[Banjo Plays] We're going to
sing the very first verse,
and you're going to make up all
the rest of the verses, okay?
It goes like this.
Who ever shall have
some good peanuts
and giving his neighbor none,
can't have any of my good peanuts
when his peanuts are gone.
And then the chorus, the part
that we all sing together,
goes like this, oh, won't it
be joyful, joyful, joyful, oh,
won't it be joyful when
his good peanuts are gone?
Now you're thinking, "How are
we going to make this song up?"
We are going to make this song
longer, and longer, and longer.
And so I want somebody to tell me
something that they like to eat.
What do you like to eat?
>> Peanuts.
>> Cathy Fink: We already
did peanuts.
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh, yes,
peanuts are good [overlapping].
>> Cathy Fink: Can you
think of something new?
>> Strawberry.
>> Cathy Fink: Strawberries.
Whoever shall have
some good strawberries
and give his neighbor none, can't
have any of my good strawberries
when his good strawberries are gone.
Okay; so what's your name?
>> Destiny.
>> Marcy Marxer: Hi, Destiny.
>> Cathy Fink: Destiny, would
you come stand right here?
Now, Destiny, we forget
what came next in this song,
I want you to remember
"strawberries," okay?
I'm peanuts, you're strawberries.
And then we all go, "Oh, won't
it be joyful, joyful, joyful, oh,
won't it be joyful and his
good peanuts and his good what?
>> Strawberries.
>> Cathy Fink: Are gone; and you
need to help us on the whole song.
Who has a food that
they want to sing about.
What do you want to sing about?
>> Blueberries.
>> Cathy Fink: Blueberries.
And what's your name?
>> Isaac.
>> Marcy Marxer: Hi, Isaac.
>> Cathy Fink: Isaac, come
stand next to Destiny.
Now, we need to start all over.
"Oh, won't it be joyful, joyful,
joyful, oh, won't it be joyful
when his good peanuts,
and his good strawberries,
and his good blueberries are gone."
Isaac, come stand on this side so
we have a little bit more -- okay.
So now we need somebody else,
and I'm going to call on you.
>> Grapes.
>> Cathy Fink: Grapes; come on up.
This is a fruit.
You guys are a fruity bunch.
Oh, here, right next to Isaac.
And what's your name?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Marcy Marxer: Hi, William.
>> Cathy Fink: Hi, William,
turn around, smile at everybody.
Okay; so who remembers them all?
We're going to sing in the chorus.
Don't tell me; everybody sing it.
Whoever shall have some good peanuts
and giving his neighbor none,
can't have any of my good peanuts
when his good peanuts are gone.
Everybody; oh, won't it be
joyful, joyful, joyful, oh,
won't it be joyful, when his good
peanuts, and his good strawberries,
and his good blueberries,
and his good grapes are gone.
Okay; let's do something
that's not a fruit.
Let's move out of the
fruit department here.
Let's see, so many people.
We need a girl with long
blonde hair, right there.
Yes.
>> Ice cream.
>> Cathy Fink: Ice cream.
Come on up here.
>> Ice cream.
>> Cathy Fink: And what's your name?
>> Natalie.
>> Cathy Fink: What is it; Natalie?
>> Cathy Fink: And what's your
favorite kind of ice cream?
>> Strawberry.
>> Cathy Fink: Strawberry.
Turn around.
>> Marcy Marxer: Strawberry
ice cream, okay.
>> Cathy Fink: I'm going to
say strawberry ice cream.
Okay; don't stand in front of him.
No, this one; right here,
right here, right here.
There you go.
>> Marcy Marxer: Perfect.
>> Cathy Fink: All
right, are you ready?
Oh, won't it be joyful, joyful,
joyful, oh, won't it be joyful
when his good peanuts,
and his good strawberries,
and his good blueberries,
and his good grapes,
and her good strawberry
ice cream are gone?
Now, I think we're
going to do one more,
but this time I think
we need a teacher.
Which teacher's going
to come up here?
[ Overlapping Comments ]
And what do you like to eat?
>> I like to eat tacos.
>> Cathy Fink: Tacos.
>> Tacos.
>> Marcy Marxer: All
right; [inaudible].
>> Cathy Fink: Okay, tacos.
Are we ready to remember
all of these?
How many things are we remembering;
one, two, three, four, five, six.
Good luck, because we're
going to leave it blank,
and you have to fill them all in.
>> Oh.
>> Cathy Fink: Oh, won't it
be joyful, joyful, joyful, oh,
won't it be joyful, when his good
peanuts, and his good strawberries,
and his good blueberries,
and his good grapes,
and her good strawberry ice cream,
and her good tacos are gone.
Okay; I think we're
going to do one more.
>> Oh, my gosh.
>> Cathy Fink: One final; I think
we're going to need another boy.
Come on up.
Come on.
[ Overlapping Comments ]
What do you want to --
what's your favorite food?
>> French fries.
>> Cathy Fink: French
fries, awesome.
[Laughter] Now, since this is
the last one, tell me what do you
like on your French fries?
>> Salt.
>> Cathy Fink: Salt?
Anything else?
>> Ketchup.
>> Cathy Fink: Salt and ketchup,
French fries with salt and ketchup.
We're going to say all that.
>> Marcy Marxer: I think
we can get that in.
>> Cathy Fink: Whoever shall
have some French fries with salt
and ketchup, and giving his
neighbor none, can't have any
of my French fries with salt and
ketchup when his French fries
with salt and ketchup are gone.
>> Marcy Marxer: Now we're
going to do it backwards.
>> Cathy Fink: Now we
have to remember them all.
No, we're not.
[Inaudible] possible.
Oh, won't it be joyful, joyful,
joyful, oh, won't it be joyful
when his good peanuts,
and his good strawberries,
and his good blueberries,
and his good grapes,
and her good strawberry ice
cream, and his good tacos,
and his good French fries with
salt and ketchup are gone.
Let's give them all a hand.
[ Applause ]
You can have a seat now because
we're going to tell a story
that you have all heard before,
except it's going to sound different
than the way that you've told it.
And this song or story is
called "The Jazzy Three Bears."
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
Once upon a time in a nursery rhyme,
there were three bears,
I said three bears.
Your turn.
Once upon a time in a
nursery rhyme, there were --
>> Three bears.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: I said --
>> Three bears.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer:
All right; first there was the --
>> Papa bear.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: Papa bear.
And then there was the --
>> Mama bear.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: Bebop, the B bear,
there was a little wee bear.
Can you do that with us?
Snap your fingers and
say, "Bebop, the B bear,
there was a little wee bear."
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
They all went walking through
the green woods a talking.
Bears were a walking,
bears were a talking.
Along came a little girl with
long, shiny, golden curls.
Her name was --
>> Goldilocks.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: Her name was --
>> Goldilocks.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: She knocked on the door
with a knock, knock, knock.
And she walked right in
because there was no lock.
She opened the door.
>> Cathy Fink: Put your
hand on the door knob.
Open it up.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: She looked around.
No one was there.
She walked right in and had
herself a ball, just eating
and a rocking and a
sleeping and all.
Started a eating, and a
rocking, and a sleeping.
[Snoring Sound] She didn't
care that no one was there.
She didn't care.
Along came the three bears.
They retired from the woods.
They were ready to sit down
to some home-cooked goods.
Yes.
>> Cathy Fink: That's your part.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer
and Children: Home-cooked goods.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer: Yes.
Well, someone's been sitting
in my chair," said the --
>> Papa bear.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer:
"Well, someone has been sitting
in my chair," said the --
>> Mama bear.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer:
Bebop the baby said the little wee
bear, "Somebody broke my chair."
>> The baby bear.
>> Cathy Fink: "Well, someone
has been eating my porridge,"
said the --
[ Overlapping Comments ]
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer:
"Someone has eaten my whole bowl
of porridge," said the --
>> Mama bear.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: Bebop,
the B bear said the little wee bear,
"In my bowl, there
is nothing there."
Well, they went upstairs to
see what they could find.
They found Goldilocks in bed.
She was asleep all the time.
>> Cathy Fink: She woke up.
>> Marcy Marxer: She
broke up that party.
>> Cathy Fink: And she
boogied on out of the there.
>> Marcy Marxer: Yes.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
>> Cathy Fink: Bye-bye,
said the papa bear.
>> Marcy Marxer: Bye-bye,
said the --
>> Mama bear.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy
Marxer: Bebop,
the B bear said the
little wee bear, "Hey,
what kind of bear was out there?
Huh?" And that is the
story of The Three Bears.
I said the Three, I said the
Three, I said The Three Bears.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
>> Cathy Fink: Excellente.
[Applause]
>> Marcy Marxer: Some of you
maybe noticed I was playing a
new instrument.
And these are called my spoons.
Now, sometimes you play
spoons hooked together,
and sometimes you play
spoons that are separate.
And you just put your
finger in-between them,
and hold them real tight, and big
spoons work really well like that.
But this is an old
traditional sound from long ago.
But it was very popular on
the streets of Washington,
D.C. between 1900 and 1920.
You'd hear this sound
going on with the music.
[Spoon Sounds] It was spoons and
[inaudible] people would play.
>> Cathy Fink: Let's have
a little spoon [inaudible].
>> Marcy Marxer: All right.
I'm going to need some
space for spoons.
[ Banjo and Spoon Sounds ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Big finish.
[ Banjo and Spoon Sounds ]
>> Cathy Fink: The spoons.
>> Marcy Marxer: All right.
>> Cathy Fink: Well,
while you do that,
I have an instrument that's
even older than the spoon.
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh my gosh.
>> What's that?
>> Cathy Fink: It's even
older than me, [inaudible]?
>> Marcy Marxer: Ooh, wow.
>> Cathy Fink: This instrument might
be the very first street instrument
ever played by anyone.
It is called a mouth boat.
Now, originally it was
probably used to hunt food
and it was probably used for
all different kinds of things.
But any stick -- I'm going
to take questions later,
any stick that will bend without
breaking and a string on it is going
to vibrate, go back and forth.
And when it vibrates, listen
to the sound it makes.
[Sounds] It actually
has a note in there.
[Hums] Can you hear that note?
[Sounds] Now, unlike the guitar
or the banjo, there's no place
to put my fingers to
make different notes.
So I get my different
notes in a sneaky way,
and that's why it's
called a "mouth bow."
Take the outside of the bow, I
put it on the outside of my mouth.
I do not eat the mouth bow.
I make my mouth in the shape of
an O. When I strum on the string,
the sound goes inside my head, and
if my head is completely empty,
then it gets louder and
comes back out to you.
Should I find out?
>> Marcy Marxer: It's
a little dangerous,
but yes I guess you should find out.
I mean, it's only dangerous in your
knowledge of yourself, I guess.
[ Instrumental Sound ]
That's pretty [inaudible].
[Laughter]
>> Cathy Fink: Now, if I make that O
bigger and smaller like fishlets --
can anybody make fishlets?
>> Yes.
>> Cathy Fink: Listen
to what happens.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
I get all those different notes.
And then if I wiggle my tongue
around inside my mouth while I make
that O bigger and smaller all at
the same time, I can make it sound
like frogs are jumping
like in a storybook.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
And you can play songs with
your mouth, though, like this.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
[ Instrumental Sounds and Singing ]
>> Marcy Marxer: Nice.
>> Cathy Fink: And this
is called a "mouth bow."
Now, one thing I want to say about
songwriting is that one of the ways
that we learned how to make
up and write our own songs was
to learn hundreds of
songs by other people.
And that's how we learn
how songs are made up.
We would learn a song, and then we'd
go, "Oh, if I want to write a song,
they have a first line, a second
line, the ends of those lines rhyme,
the third line, a fourth line,
the ends of those lines rhyme,"
and we learned how to do that.
Now, in this song,
not only did the man
who write this make a great song,
but he also gave us an opportunity
to teach you how to yodel.
>> Marcy Marxer: Okay.
[ Banjo Plays ]
>> Cathy Fink: And we performed this
song in the Library of Congress,
where we all are right now, in 1988.
>> Marcy Marxer: Whoa.
That was the 1900s, kids.
Isn't that amazing?
>> Cathy Fink: With a
lady named Patsy Montana,
who was the first woman in country
music to sell one million records,
which she did so long ago you'd
have to read about it in a book.
She did it in 1935.
Now, before we sing this song, we're
going to teach you how to yodel.
All right; who knows
what yodeling is?
>> Yodelaheho.
>> Cathy Fink: Excellent.
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh, yes.
>> Cathy Fink: That was excellent.
Yodelaheho.
Now, you know what, yodeling is
made up of your vowel sounds,
A for the low note,
E for the high note.
I'm going to make a sound,
you make it back to me.
[ Yodeling ]
Perfect. Those are two
of your vowel sounds.
Do you recognize those?
>> Yes.
>> Cathy Fink: Okay; now I'm
going to add a third vowel,
and it's going to be O. Listen.
[ Yodeling ]
All right; here's the trick
to professional cowboy
or cowgirl yodeling.
We're going to take the word yodel,
Y O D E L, we're going to put it
in front of A E, and it's
going to sound like this.
[ Yodeling ]
Great; now we're going to add
that other syllable that goes --
[ Yodeling ]
All right; now I'm going
to make it trickier.
[ Yodeling ]
Okay; here's a trick W.
All right; here is a joke that
I learned from a second grader.
Knock-knock.
>> Who's there?
>> Cathy Fink: Little old lady.
>> Little old lady who?
>> Cathy Fink: I knew you
could yodel, so we want you
to yodel with us on this song.
[ Music and Yodeling ]
Now, here's how she did it.
You're going to do it with us.
Are you ready?
[ Music and Yodeling ]
Do you think you can
sing that with us?
Here we go; try it.
[ Music and Yodeling ]
Your turn.
You know what, we're going
to show you what it sounds
like when she slides down the
mountain fast, and you get to choose
if we go fast, very fast -- see
we have one V, or very, very fast,
two Vs. But remember,
when we are done,
you're going to do
whatever you told us to do.
So what should we do, fast,
very fast, or very, very fast.
Marcy, there are mostly --
>> Marcy Marxer: It
looks like the three --
>> Cathy Fink: Very, very
fast is being held up.
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh, my gosh,
I saw very, very, very fast.
>> Cathy Fink: I saw -- yes, okay,
Marcy, I think you're going to have
to wind up a little bit so we can
play really fast, yodel really fast.
But remember, when you're
done, it's your turn.
Are you ready, Marcy?
>> Marcy Marxer: I'm ready.
[ Music and Yodeling ]
>> Cathy Fink: It's your turn.
Sit up straight, take a big breath.
[ Music and Yodeling ]
Nice job. All right, let's travel.
One thing that you can do
at libraries and you can do
in books is you can travel
without going anyplace at all,
just by reading about these places.
We're going to travel to Ghana.
And in this song, this is
a game and song from Ghana,
and a little bit of a dance.
And so we all get to stand up.
Everybody stand up
right where you are.
And first we're going to
hear Marcy play the drum.
And then you'll follow
my directions.
Okay, here we go.
[ Background Talking ]
You go ahead and stretch up
for a second; up, up, up, up.
Who can touch the ceiling
at the Library of Congress?
Okay. Now, listen to the beat
and get the beat in your head.
Good; side to side.
Get the beat in your
head up and down.
Good; now your shoulders.
Excellent.
Now in your arms.
[ Drum Plays ]
And hips. Come on, you
guys, move those hips.
I'm older than you.
And your knees, and your
feet, and everywhere.
All right; I'm going to sing
a line and you sing it back
to me while you keep the beat.
Here we go.
[ Drums and Singing ]
What are we singing about?
And faster.
[ Drums and Singing ]
You guys are awesome.
Everybody sit down.
Awesome.
[ Background Talking ]
I'll tell you what
we're going to do.
We're going to take a couple
of minutes to talk to you
and answer some questions you have
about what we do, and how we do it.
And then we're going to sing a
couple more songs at the end.
So does anybody have a question?
>> Are you famous?
>> Cathy Fink: Are we famous?
>> Marcy Marxer: Well, some
people think we're famous.
>> Cathy Fink: We have --
>> Marcy Marxer: If
you don't know us,
then you probably don't
think we're famous.
[Laughter]
>> Cathy Fink: And you know what,
famous people are just
plain old people.
But we have two Grammy Awards,
and we have 14 Grammy nominations,
and we've traveled
all over the world.
But it doesn't matter how famous
you are, because whoever is in front
of you right this minute
as a performers,
those are the most important people.
You guys are the most important
people to us this morning.
And we're so happy to
be spending it with you.
>> I'm good at playing piano.
>> Cathy Fink: You're
good at playing piano?
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh,
that's fabulous.
>> Cathy Fink: That's excellent.
>> Marcy Marxer: Fabulous.
>> Cathy Fink: Now, we're going
to ask for questions, okay,
if you want to know something
about what we do, maybe something
about writing songs, or
learning about songs, or anybody?
>> Marcy Marxer: And you
had your hand up earlier.
>> Cathy Fink: Yes; and she'll
come -- we'll get to them.
What do you -- what's your question?
>> I don't know.
>> Marcy Marxer: That's okay.
That's okay.
>> Cathy Fink: You forgot.
I forget questions all the time.
What's your question?
>> Why does the microphone
look like a bow and arrow?
>> Cathy Fink: The mouth bow
looks like a bow and arrow
because basically any bow is
something bent and one string.
And it's possible that even when
this was being used as a bow
and arrow -- and I have never ever,
and never will use it as a weapon,
but listen, [sound] that's
probably where someone first heard
that sound and heard music in it.
And there are versions of
mouth bows all over the world.
It's really amazing.
Somebody had a question back there.
Do you still have one; no?
Any questions?
I'll tell you -- I'll give you one
more question, and then we're going
to sing a song and see if
you have any questions.
>> Why do you write songs?
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh, [overlapping].
>> Cathy Fink: That
is a great question.
>> Marcy Marxer: For
many, many reasons.
Sometimes we write songs because
we want to communicate an idea,
and especially kids'
songs, you know,
we can have so much
fun with kids' songs.
And then we can also do
songs that have a meaning,
something that might help
them in school or in life.
And there's so much inspiration
with kids, because kids have
such great senses of humor.
So that gives us a lot to work with.
>> Cathy Fink: Here,
Marcy, give me the guitar.
I have a great example.
Why do we write a certain song?
We won a Grammy Award
for an album called
"Bon Apptit: Musical Food Fun."
There's a small chance I'm going
to play this in the correct key.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
That's not the right key.
Let's try this key.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
There are a lot of teachers,
and parents, and nutritionists
who wanted us to write a song about
the most important meal of the day.
We not only wrote the song,
we decided to turn it
into a little opera.
And the for Marcy.
Marcy, do you know what the most
important meal of the day is?
>> Breakfast.
>> Cathy Fink: Yes;
my most important meal
of the day is my lunch,
because my dad packs it for me,
and it's always fun to
see what's in there,
and I never know what
it's going to be.
[Laughter] Marcy, I think
lunch is a very important meal,
but it might not be the most
important meal of the day,
because your day starts
before lunch.
And you have to go to
school with a lot of energy.
I'm trying to give you a hint.
>> Marcy Marxer: It's dinner.
>> No.
>> Marcy Marxer: I love dinner.
We all sit around and talk.
We talk about the day, and we talk
about how school went,
and so [inaudible].
[Laughter]
>> Cathy Fink: Okay; I'm
going to give you one more.
>> Marcy Marxer: Wait a minute,
I sense the kids think
I'm wrong about this.
What do you think the most
important meal of the day is?
>> Breakfast.
>> Marcy Marxer: Ah, okay.
>> Cathy Fink: I want you
all to take your fists
and make the biggest
muscles you have.
And when we say, "Breakfast
power," I want you
to repeat, "Breakfast power."
Now, remember, we're at
the Library of Congress,
and it's really supposed
to be quiet and polite.
But when we say, "Breakfast
power," we are allowed to yell,
and it really doesn't matter.
This is when you get
to break the rules.
Are you ready?
Let's try it, breakfast power."
>> Breakfast power.
[ Instrumental Sounds ]
[ Instrumental Sounds and Singing ]
>> Cathy Fink: Your turn.
>> Breakfast power.
>> Cathy Fink and Marcy Marxer:
We need calories for energy.
[Inaudible] mystery,
it's breakfast power.
>> Breakfast power.
[ Instrumental Sounds and Singing ]
[ Instrumental Sounds and Humming ]
Breakfast power.
[ Instrumental Sounds and Singing ]
Breakfast Power
>> Cathy Fink: That was fun.
>> Marcy Marxer: I
heard you that time.
[Laughter]
>> Cathy Fink: Now, one of our
jobs as songwriters when we work
with kids a lot is to make up
songs where we have a ton of fun,
and we also learn something.
Like I bet if somebody
says to you tomorrow,
"What's the most important meal of
the day," what are you going to say?
>> Breakfast.
>> Cathy Fink: You're
going to say breakfast
because you just learned
something, but we goofed off
and had fun at the same time.
Sometimes that's a
reason we write a song.
Sometimes songs are written
in a whole different way.
Now, check this out.
Marcy, will you play guitar?
>> Marcy Marxer: Sure.
>> Cathy Fink: Will you
play guitar in the key of G?
>> Marcy Marxer: I think I can.
>> Cathy Fink: What's been
going on in the weather lately?
>> Rain.
>> Cathy Fink: Rain, lots of rain.
We have a friend named
Bob [inaudible],
who used to be a street singer.
He used to stand on the
street corners and play four
or five instruments at
once, and get people singing
and playing along with him.
And then he'd pack up and he'd go
to the bus stop, and he'd go home.
One day, he packed up, he went to
the bus stop and it was raining.
I can hear the rain.
Can you hear it?
>> Yes.
>> Cathy Fink: It was
raining so hard.
And there were ten people at that
bus stop, and there tall people,
and short people, and thin
people, and heavy people,
and there were people
of all different colors.
And he looked around
and you know what,
it rained on every single person.
The rain didn't skip anybody.
And so we're all the same.
And he made up a song
based on that experience.
A lot of our songs are
based on experiences.
And the song is called
"When the Rain Comes Down,"
and it's about love and equality.
I'm going to teach it
to you in sign language.
I want you to put your hands in the
air and spread your fingers apart
and say, "When the
rain comes down -- "
>> When the rain comes down.
>> Cathy Fink: Good.
It comes down on -- and here's
how we say everyone, everyone.
>> Everyone.
>> Cathy Fink: Then we
say that whole line again.
Do it again.
When the rain comes down,
it comes down on everyone.
Now, no matter, it doesn't matter --
and you just go like this with
your hands, if you're rich,
you've got a handful of coins
and you throw them away; or poor,
play with a hole in your sleeve.
No matter if you're great
big, or what's this?
>> Small.
>> Cathy Fink: Small; when the rain
comes down, it comes down on us --
>> All.
>> Cathy Fink: All.
Perfect. And here's
how the song goes.
Oh, wait, we're going to learn
a couple of other things.
When the sun shines down, you draw
the sun and make the rays come down.
And here's my favorite,
when the flowers bloom,
you make a flower bloom
from behind your hand.
Let's make a big garden
together, everybody, right now.
When the flowers bloom -- perfect.
Okay; Marcy, if you play guitar,
we'll sing "When The
Rain Comes Down."
[Guitar Plays] When the rain comes
down, it comes down on everyone.
When the rain comes down,
it comes down on everyone.
No matter if you're rich or poor,
no matter if you're great or small,
when the rain comes down,
it comes down on us all.
Now, we can have a whole
new verse to this song
by just changing "rain" to "sun."
>> To "sun."
>> Cathy Fink: Here we go.
When the sun shines down,
it shines down on everyone.
No matter if you're rich or poor,
no matter if you're great or small,
when the sun shines down,
it shines down on us all.
Who remembers what else we did?
Rain and sun makes
what bloom; flowers.
>> Flowers.
>> Cathy Fink: Let's
make our garden.
When the flowers bloom,
they're blooming for everyone.
No matter if you're rich or poor,
no matter if you're great or small,
when the flowers bloom,
they're blooming for us all.
Let's do when the rain comes
down; everybody together.
When the rain comes down --
that's beautiful, it
comes down on everyone.
When the rain comes down,
it comes down on everyone.
No matter if you're rich or poor,
no matter if you're great or small,
when the rain comes down,
it comes down on us all.
Now, one time we're going to sing
it just our hands, not our voices.
You ready; you have to think
of the words when you do that.
[ Guitar Plays and Humming ]
When the rain comes down,
it comes down on us all.
That was so beautiful.
Now we're going to learn how
to clap in sign language.
Instead of clapping and
making noise, we go like this.
That's so cool.
You've been such a
fabulous audience.
Does anybody else have
questions for us?
>> Marcy Marxer: Did you have
a question in the white shirt?
>> Could you change the name
on the sign to "rainbows?"
>> Marcy Marxer: Yes,
you could; yes you could.
>> Cathy Fink: Absolutely.
Let's do it.
That's a great idea.
>> Marcy Marxer: Great idea.
>> Cathy Fink: Let's
change it to "rainbows."
I don't know the sign to rainbows.
Does anybody here know the sign?
>> Marcy Marxer: I think
it's like this, Cathy.
I think it's like this.
>> Cathy Fink: Oh, okay, like this?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Shall we sing, "When
the rainbows shine?"
>> Yes.
>> Cathy Fink: When the rainbows
shine, it's shining for everyone.
When the rainbows shine,
they're shining for everyone.
No matter if you're rich or poor,
no matter if you're great or small,
when the rainbows shine,
they're shining for us all.
And there --
>> Marcy Marxer: That's nice.
>> Cathy Fink: You helped
write a new verse to that song.
Congratulations.
Who else -- who hasn't asked
a question and has one?
Do you have one?
>> Do you learn a lot of
songs from other people?
>> Cathy Fink: Do we learn a lot of
songs from other people; yes, we do.
We learn a whole lot of
songs from other people,
and we write a lot of songs.
But the more songs that we listen
to, and the more different styles
of music that we listen to,
the more influences we have
in what we want to create.
It's a great question.
>> How many songs did you learn?
>> Cathy Fink: How many songs
have we learned from other people?
>> Marcy Marxer: Hmm.
>> Cathy Fink: My guess is that over
the years, we've probably learned
about 2,000 songs from other people.
And then over the years, we've
probably written about 500 songs.
>> Wow.
>> Cathy Fink: Other questions?
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What?
>> I forgot.
>> Cathy Fink: You forgot?
That's okay.
>> Marcy Marxer: That's okay.
>> Cathy Fink: Do you
have another question?
>> Can you change the
songs to [inaudible]?
>> Cathy Fink: Can you
change the songs for what?
>> Jewels; like jury, jewels.
>> Cathy Fink: Jury jewels?
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh, sure.
>> Cathy Fink: In this song --
>> Marcy Marxer: Do
whatever you want.
>> Cathy Fink: You can but, you
know, this song isn't so much
about things, jewels are things, as
it is about feelings and equality.
So that would be a
tricky thing in this song.
You know, some songs are about
things, but this one is really
about love and equality,
and it feels like jewels don't
really fit [overlapping].
>> Marcy Marxer: Well, you know,
that's an idea I'd never heard.
It would be really, really fun to
go giving jewelry out to everybody.
>> Cathy Fink: So we've got
time for one last question.
Is there somebody who
has not asked one,
someone who has not
had their hand up?
>> Marcy Marxer: Oh.
>> Cathy Fink: You haven't.
>> Do you like the other kinds
of songs that people hear?
>> Marcy Marxer: Yes;
we like a lot of songs.
I like music from almost
every type of music.
I like pop music, I like
rock and roll music.
And --
>> Cathy Fink We both do; and
you know what, when you leave,
you're getting a CD of ours
called "Banjo the Beat Box,"
and it's got a combination of
folk music and hip-hop on it.
We love hip-hop.
And it's got a friend of ours with
us, a guy named "Christylez Bacon,"
and he does hip-hop together
with us, and it's crazy fun.
We want to thank you for being
such a fabulous audience.
Marcy and I are going to
thank you in sign language.
>> Marcy Marxer: [Overlapping].
And now thank you with our hands.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.